have you seen this bulletproof train
that the North Korean dictator is riding
around in it's bulletproof it's huge and
it's what the North Korean leader uses
to leave the country because he's kind
of afraid of flying or at least that's
the rumor Kim Jong-un hasn't left the
country in three years but he just
decided to do so to go to Russia to
visit President Vladimir Putin he snaked
up the coast of North Korea passed this
really bizarre place where China Russia
and North Korea borders all come
together and eventually made it to
Eastern Russia by the way this train
only goes like 30 or 40 miles an hour
max speed because they want it to be
extra safe Kim is reportedly joined by
his Munitions and weapons guy leading
many experts to speculate that this trip
is about Russia asking North Korea for
weapons reminder that Vladimir Putin is
very isolated from the world right now
and is struggling to get the weapons and
materials he needs to continue his war
in Ukraine so he's turning to a fellow
Outcast North Korea for help so now we
just wait and see if North Korean
weapons start flowing into Russia if you
want to better understand global
politics follow for more